sapete ragazzi che la curiosità in tutto
questo è che io non vorrei fare speciali
perché gli speciali che faccio ci mette
una vita a farli perché sono video
speciali quindi ogni volta che
raggiungono un milione di iscritti nuovo
dico bene e questo era l'ultimo ci siamo
levati dai cazzo tutti gli speciali e
invece puntualmente nel aggiungiamo un
altro quindi alla fine sono nella merda
ragazzi minuti a questo nuovo video sono
fa vj ed oggi siamo su un video speciale
mettiamola così per i 3 milioni di
iscritti nel vino di oggi ho deciso di
raccontarvi delle curiosità che non
conosce praticamente nessuno e niente
vediamo che cosa esce fuori visto che
siamo in così tanti ragazzi molti di voi
non sanno neanche perché mi chiamo fa vj
quindi è giusto che miri presenti di
nuovo anche se l'ho già fatto quindi la
prima curiosità la sanno tutti gli altri
che ti chiami fa vj allora il mio
nickname ragazzi e fa vj anche se io mi
chiamo lorenzo quindi col mio nome non
c'entra una bega perché nel lontano 2004
quando giocai per la prima volta world
of warcraft che un videogioco online
incontrai un giocatore online chiamato
fa vj era la prima volta che incontrava
un giocatore online nella mia vita non
era mai successo e mi rimase impresso il
suo nome quindi da quel momento in poi
vi ho iniziato a chiamarmi fa vigili o
[ __ ] il nome fatalmente cagare il
nome fa vj che l'avrà scritto a caso
sulla tastiera mango solo ricorda quindi
sono iscritto a youtube per la prima
volta nel 2007 ma ho iniziato a fare
video da youtube e quindi commentando
solo mettendoci la voce e non la faccia
che vista la situazione forse era anche
meglio iniziato a fare lo youtuber nel
2011 con due miei amici abbiamo aperto
un canale di gaming nel 2013 ho iniziato
a fare video su videogiochi horror sul
mio canale che ho aperto fa vige tv che
è questo qua è cominciato tutto da un
videogioco chiamato slann der man è un
videogioco che ai tempi andava
tantissimo su youtube l'ho visto per la
prima volta ha fatto da più di pai e mi
era piaciuto talmente tanto che ho detto
minchia che gioco strano provo a farlo
anch'io vedere che succede poi adesso
non succede quasi più ma agli inizi
della mia carriera di youtube per questo
motivo perché anche io facevo indie
horror mi dice un sacco di gente mi
scriveva e mafai video perché copie pd
pare ora su youtube tutti fanno il cazzo
che vogliono quindi non c'è più questa
cosa però un tempo si usava dire a
qualsiasi youtuber copy più di paio però
io sono sempre stato un suo fan
voi non avete idea di quale sia il salva
schermo del mio tel
e da circa 7 8 mesi che ho questo salva
schermo tenetevi pronti si è esattamente
quello che pensate e no non è un cazzo
di photoshop ci sono più di pai e
marques che tengono il mio libro scopi
di fi che probabilmente ha
un'espressione dicendo ma che cazzo e
questa roba prove la mia partner di
youtube è la stessa di pd pie che gli
hanno fatto avere libro mio e si era
fatto la foto con libro me l'aveva
mandata probabilmente l'avrà buttato
adesso nei peggio cassonetti
dell'immondizia è al sicuro però intanto
che la foto ce l'ho fatta e cazzi nella
mia vita mi sono fidanzato tre volte la
prima è durata un anno e mezzo la
seconda due mesi un cazzo e la terza è
durata un altro anno e mezzo e non erano
di dominio pubblico perché non ho mai
voluto mettere una mia scelta di privacy
non ho mai voluto mettere in luce
persone alla cazzo di cane a scuola che
cosa pensavano i tuoi professori di te
di acconto una cosa allora quando
raggiunto un certo numero di iscritti su
youtube
la voce si era diffusa in tutta la
scuola mettiamola così ed era arrivato
anche ai professori ora il 90 per cento
di questi professori erano contenti c'è
nel senso ne frega un cazzo
mentre c'era un professore in
particolare che sapeva del fatto che io
facevo video su youtube ed era un
professore sicko patico serio è
praticamente cosa era successo un giorno
entra in classe fa la lezione tutta
quanta esce prima di io ero vicino alla
porta di uscita di mio banco da vicino
alla porta d'uscita quindi professore mi
mi è passato davanti per uscire prima di
uscire mette il piede fuori dalla stanza
mi vede che sono lì rientra nella stanza
mi guarda e dice ostuni
io so ed esce porca [ __ ] date un oscar
a quell'uomo me la ricorderò sempre
questa coppa che me lo disse con un aria
minacciosa della serie non è che fa il
mio so non è che fa il furbo adesso che
fai livido ios ios o le cose gli rodeva
abbastanza il culo questa cosa la so
perché per me l'avevano detto però già
che ci siamo per peggiorare la
situazione professore se stai guardando
questo video la sua materia mi faceva
pure cagare
quindi siamo a posto dj perché fa il
video in solitario come potete vedere
negli ultimi video ho iniziato solo
ultimamente c'è solo gli aiuti
i mesi a fare collaborazioni perché io
ragazzi sono sempre stato molto
solitario come persona sono tipo ninja
lavoro da solo uccidono le persone da
solo ti sei mai innamorato di una fan
partiamo dal presupposto che tutte e tre
le ragazze con le quali sono stato
seguivano il mio canale youtube non le
consideravo fan perché una fan vera e
propria e quando ci riesci insieme ti
chiama fa vj
io non credo non potrei mai uscire con
una persona che mi chiama fa vince la
potrei mai fare potrebbe anche essere
megan fox trot appena megan fox forse sì
diciamo che megan fox selena gomez sono
scusate per la cosa del fa vj chiamatemi
come cazzo mi pare prosegue the uscire
io ci sono ma la vera partita sia un po
come se daniel radcliffe uscisse con una
che lo chiama harry potter
quando andavo alle superiori o quasi
denunciato un mio compagno che era
invidioso della mia carriera su youtube
vabbè prevedibile che aveva fotografato
il libretto di scuola dove c'era il nome
cognome indirizzo e numero di telefono
aveva aperto un blog dove voleva
metterlo pubblico l'aveva fatto anche in
anonimato quindi non aveva detto che era
stato lui aveva aperto solo il blog e io
l'avevo visto e non sapevo chi fosse non
era neanche sicuro che fosse un mio
compagno pensavo che fosse uno che era
riuscito a mettere le mani sul mio
libretto scolastico
prima di denunciare la suddetta persona
abbiamo scritto sul mio gruppo di classe
di whatsapp ragazzi guardate che sto per
denunciare chi sta e chi ha fatto sta
roba se per caso è stato qualcuno di voi
toglietelo perché io domani devo avviare
tutto quanto tempo 5 e dico cinque
minuti ed era sparito tutto mi fa troppo
ridere quando ci ripenso da quando ho
iniziato la mia carriera su youtube
sempre detto di essere di un paesino
vicino a torino chiamato borgaro in
realtà non era vero perché il mio
paesino non era questo era un altro
paesino sempre in provincia di torino ma
molto più piccolo non ho mai voluto dire
la il mio reale paese d'origine perché
ai tempi abitavo lì molti ragazzini
sarebbero venuti a suonarmi il
campanello
ogni tre secondi cosa che veramente
successo ed anche per questo mi sono
trasferito e non solo per questo ma
anche per questo mi sono trasferito
purtroppo avere tanti iscritti anche un
prezzo se così lo vogliamo chiamare che
sono gli stalker cioè la gente che passa
la vita a cercare di capire dove cazzo
abiti per venirti a suonare il
campanello ed era diventato ingestibile
che nel senso ogni tre secondi
c'era gente che mi suonava il campanello
allora poi mi sono trasferito e non
avevo neanche detto che quello era il
mio paese pensate se avessi detto dove
abitavo è una cosa che purtroppo succede
perché la persona che scopre dove abiti
dice adesso vado a trovare però poi non
è l'unica farlo è la tua vita diventa
morte perché non puoi neanche andare al
cesso comunque adesso l'ho detto dove
abitavo perché tanto non ci abito più
quindi fotte sega all'esame di maturità
ho portato youtube
ve lo giuro una delle slide della mia
tesina di maturità
era questa va bene terzo il mio promosso
era il prof di prima che lui sa lui
sapeva quindi mi ha promosso lui è che
ci crediate o no collegato tutte le
materie con la mia tesina anche
matematica l'ultima domanda è fai video
per soldi non ho mai risposto realmente
a questa domanda perché non ce n'è mai
stata veramente l'occasione quindi già
che ci sono lo faccio adesso quindi io
faccio video perché fare video su
youtube è il mio lavoro però la vera
risposta è faccio video anche perché il
mio lavoro ma non solo perché è il mio
lavoro nel 2007 quando ho aperto il mio
canale ve l'ho detto all'inizio oppure
nel 2011 quando abbiamo iniziato a fare
gli youtubers con i miei amici non si
poteva neanche guadagnare da youtube
complessivamente ho fatto video per
cinque anni senza ricevere introiti poi
nel 2013
ho preso la mia prima partner con
youtube ho iniziato a guadagnare dai
miei video ma questa era una cosa che ai
tempi io non pensavo neanche che si
potesse fare cioè quando mi hanno detto
ha poi guadagnare quei video cosa è mai
avrei pensato che questo sarebbe
diventato il mio lavoro ho iniziato a
dedicarci più tempo perché comunque un
hobby non potevano deve diventare un
lavoro non può essere più solo un hobby
deve esserci più dedizione io infatti
faccio un video al giorno però è
sbagliato dire che io faccio questo solo
perché il mio lavoro lo è diventato ma
in primis e questa è una cosa che dico a
chiunque può iniziare a fare lo youth
huber king
non può fare lo youtuber se lo fa solo
perché vuole che diventi il suo lavoro è
sbagliato perché non gli verrà mai e poi
mai un video fatto bene non ci sarà mai
quel contenuto divertente perché si vede
che lo fai perché lo devi fare ed è
sbagliato io ho avuto la fortuna e
questo me lo ripeto sempre di essere
riuscito a trasformare il mio hobby
quindi una cosa che mi è sempre piaciuto
a fare senza ricevere nulla in cambio
nel mio lavoro quindi è diventato con il
tempo anche il mio lavoro
youtube è stato e sempre rimarrà la mia
vera e forse anche unica aggiungerei la
mia vera e unica passione negli anni se
un giorno lo youtube non dovesse essere
più il mio lavoro non farei
probabilmente un video al giorno quello
sicuramente perché un video al giorno mi
toglie tantissimo tempo alle volte non
possono anche uscire però non smetterei
di fare video perché per me fare video è
sempre stato un motivo di sfogo come voi
guardate i video che vi distraete io li
faccio e mi distraggo per me una
distrazione fare video è un hobby quindi
non smetterei di fare video se questo
smettesse da un giorno all'altro di
essere mio lavoro non lo farei
semplicemente tutti i giorni e questa è
la unica vera verità che la gente ci
creda o meno perché poi ovviamente
ognuno crede al cazzo che vuole quindi
ragazzi in conclusione se oggi siamo
arrivati a 3 milioni di iscritti
ho cercato di dare tutto me stesso da
quattro anni a questa parte per far
uscire ogni giorno contenuti che fossero
divertenti per voi e soprattutto voi non
avete mai e poi mai smesso di
supportarmi questo questa cosa per me
vale più del traguardo dei tre milioni
perché 3 milioni alla fine è un numero
ragazzi sono numeri c'è veramente non
posso basare la mia vita sui traguardi
fatti di numeri io ero contentissimo
anche quando eravamo in 10 mila quello
che è sempre stato importante non è
tanto il numero d'iscritti ma il valore
che c'è dietro tutta questa cosa il
fatto di riuscire a rendere felici così
tante persone
però siamo arrivati qua non so neanche
dove andremo a finire
ma chi cazzo se ne frega jolo quindi
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto
era un video un po particolare forse
avete visto molto di pi lorenzo in
questo video che fa dj perché erano cose
che avevo piacere di condividere con voi
perché
non lo so perché forse per avvicinarci
un po di più perché poi alla fine
abbiamo sempre le cose da scoprire gli
uni con gli altri quindi è bello
condividere queste cose io ragazzi spero
che questo video vi sia piaciuto ci sarà
uno speciale un secondo speciale diverso
ma questo sarà una sottospecie di
challenge eccola solito seguito è
piaciuto sotto commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che venivi
adottata nelle schizzare sensi fischiati
vinci diavolo proseguito bella ragazzi